huit ex ministre de la justice signe
manifeste aujourd'hui dans laquelle il
demande une réforme urgente du droit de
la famille au québec et parce que ça
survienne a finalement six ans après le
jugement de la cour suprême dans la
sphère eric versus lola bien sûr ce sont
toujours les enfants qui sont affectés
généralement pour ne pas dire tout le
temps parler séparation de parents linda
goupil signataires du manifeste
ex-ministre de la justice et avocate en
droit d'affirmer bonjour madame goupil
alors vous me dire un peu si c'est
étonnant ça semble être est d'une
évidence tout à fait limpide mais après
un gouvernement que bouger dans ce
dossier là vous avez vous avez raison
est proposé c'est une réforme globale du
droit de la famille à la évidemment on
ne souhaite pas que ce soit fait à la
pièce alors lorsque vient le temps de
travail et bien il faut qu'il ya une
volonté pour le faire
je pense que maintenant on ça il ya un
nouveau gouvernement il ya aussi une
ouverture de madame la milice qui a bien
mentionné hier qu'elle trouvait que
c'était juste et pertinent que l'on
puisse bien sûr s'y attarder mais en
même temps comme c'est quelque chose qui
va demander un certain temps qui se vit
une réforme du droit de la famille il
fallait qu'il y ait des gens qui peut se
pencher alors pour ça que nous montre
que moi personnellement et d'autres qui
ont scié il y avait un travail colossal
qui a été fait par un comité de sages
des membres experts qui ont consacré
leur temps près de deux ans pour
regarder ce qui s'était fait jusqu'à
maintenant depuis les années 1980 fait
un portrait socio démographiques des
changements familiaux du québec et c'est
comme ça aussi qu'ils en sont arrivés à
faire des recommandations qui font plein
de sens alors dans ce contexte là bas il
est important de se mettre au travail et
de proposer un véritable réforme du
droit de la famille parce que lorsqu'on
comprend dans le moment c'est que les
enfants de parents
de fait des conjoints de fait sont moins
bien traités que les autres ils ont
moins de moins de protection la liberté
choisir son type d'union est-ce que ça
comme préséance sur le bien-être des
enfants on dirait dans le moment alors
en fuite est important c'est la liberté
de choisir si on veut se marier
conjoints de fait outre 20 c'est
important de respecter cela mais à
partir du moment où on a des enfants
qu'on ait le désir d'enfant puis quand
on a le bonheur d'en avoir
il est impératif que l'on peut se doter
d'un régime parental qui ferait en sorte
qu'ils protègeraient d'abord les enfants
la famille mais quel que soit le choix
des parents c'est qu'on puisse s'assurer
qu'il n'y ait pas de désavantages
économiques qui soient attribués à tard
en plus qu'à l'eau tout donne un exemple
un coup tu le quittes conjoints de fait
par exemple de trois enfants et que la
maman a eu un travail je dray - rires -
réguliers se retrouve avec des revenus
modestes arrive la séparation des vous
savez qu'actuellement c'est quand même 6
sur 10 alors ce qui fait en sorte qu' on
a des tables de succession de passes
alimentaires ou les deux parents doivent
contribuer en proportion de leurs
revenus
prenons un parent qui gagne 30 mille
dollars il le droit un montant 2155 pour
subvenir à ses besoins
puis on a le papa lui qui peut gagner 60
mail ou 70 parce qu'il n'a jamais eu une
interruption en raison de la grossesse
arrive les séparations la maison et au
nom de papa maman doit contribuer et en
plus elle n'a pas les économiquement les
ressources nécessaires pour offrir un
toit convenable à ses enfants et aussi
ce que ça amène c'est plaisant sans très
souvent ne peuvent plus faire les
activités auxquelles ils avaient
légitimement le droit de continuer donc
il est très clairement je fais de la
médiation je rencontre des gens à tous
les jours 80% de mon travail
et dans ce sens là malgré toute la bonne
volonté il n'y a rien qui actuellement
protège les enfants ainsi que le
conjoint qui
n'a pas les ressources financières pour
subvenir correctement aux besoins des
enfants et à ses propres besoins
bon bah je souhaite pour tous ces petits
que le mouvement là continue de prendre
de l'ampleur et un momentum alors on
voit on va voir ce que ça va donner
merci non pour être sûr tout ce qui
était partante et qui ont fait cette
réforme
oui nos p'tits loups vont bien aller les
parents vont bien à l'ena société va
être plus heureux ce dont devraient tous
sereins tout et partout comme on dit
merci et encore merci de vous dit avoir
intéressé